[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 27
septembre des regards des visages des
émotions l'artiste peintre nathalie
dhainaut les couches sur une toile elle
expose actuellement ses oeuvres à
guyancourt
il fête ses 50 ans l'anniversaire de sa
reconstruction de lycée militaire de
saint cyr l'école édite un livre pour
découvrir son histoire son chef
d'établissement nous en dira un peu plus
et nous recevrons deux membres de
nguinth un jeune groupe francilien de
rock stoner le 6 octobre prochain ils
seront sur la scène de la batterie de
l'huile en cours en plateau avec nous ce
soir le colonel thiry assonion du lycée
de saint cyr bonsoir et de membres du
groupe grégoire et bruno bonsoir mais
avant on va faire un tour sur une
exposition alors elle est fascinée par
le trait celui au crayon au pinceau ou
encore au fusain l'artiste peintre
nathalie dhainaut expose en ce moment à
guyancourt
elle observe les autres et retranscrire
l'émotion sur sa toile regarder
[Musique]
est-ce vous qui les observait ou est ce
qui vous regarde les visages de nathalie
dhainaut sont partout ils attirent le
spectateur comme la créatrice elle même
des foules ce qui nous ça m'a toujours
interpellé les foules des visages la
personnalité des gens la multitude
l'unicité
bon voila et je trouve que on peut dire
tellement de choses en à travers un
visage
[Musique]
j'ai fait des natures mortes aussi j'ai
fait 2 2
des paysages mais ç'a toujours été les
visages qui m'ont qui m'ont plu les
différentes expressions et
le lien qui entre les gens des visages
d'inconnus de célébrité mais toujours
expressif nathalie dayiot travail
d'après photo encre de chine marqueur
bâton d'huile peinture des techniques
multiples mais un point commun le trait
j'ai beaucoup été influencé par
giacometti
évidemment qu'ils travaillaient beaucoup
comme ça part très partouche et je
trouve que c'est c'est vivant c'est
vibrant et c'est vrai que la difficulté
c'est de faire cohabiter le le trait la
peinture c'est une réflexion que de tous
les jours d'être et pénétrant émouvant
et parfois des devinettes dans cette
toile arriverez vous à trouver l'intrus
[Musique]
et notre exposition totalement
différente celle ci à villepreux 35
plaques de rues sont à découvrir des
plaques ancienne mairesse est récente
chacune d'entre elles est accompagnée
d'un texte explicatif vous découvrirez
par exemple histoire d'âme et des
brocarts historien et conseiller
municipal de la commune vers 18 170 et
pour les vip rosien intéresser ces
plaques peuvent aussi être récupérés
cette exposition est née ici je puis
dire suite un changement donc de la
signalétique que nous avons fait dans la
commune pour uniformiser un peu
l'ensemble des plaques
et puis il en est ressorti l'idée de
pouvoir exposer dans un premier temps
aux villes provient nono plaques de rues
qui représente une histoire aussi bien
pour une personne que par rapport à un
lieu où par rapport à un événement
historique
on continue cette culture avec notre
premier invité le colonel thiry assonion
alors vous êtes le chef de corps du
lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école et
cette année je disais tout à l'heure
l'établissement fête ses 50 ans ceux de
la reconstruction avant 2016 il ya une
cérémonie et vous avez décidé d'éditer
un livre
oui mon choix nous avons décidé d'éditer
un livre pour rappeler pour expliquer
qu'elle était l'histoire du lycée
une histoire qui n'a pas commencé avec
madame de maintenon pour le lycée
militaire de saint-cyr mais il ya bien
50 ans le 4 novembre 1966 inauguré par
pierre messmer voilà il se livre était
l'objet pour nous de de montrer qu'elle
était un autre projet éducatif qui je
crois très original alors on l'a précisé
on dit 50 ans la reconstruction ce qu'il
à l'établissement lui a été détruit
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale dans
le texte c'est que le laissez vous aller
plus en avant
alors on reprend nos racines
parce qu'en fait c'est lui ont toujours
été dédiée à l'éducation
madame de maintenon l'école spéciale
militaire de saint cyr puis pendant
quelques années après le bombardement
bien plus rien des ruines et en 66
général de gaulle a décidé de recréer
cet établissement toujours dédié à
l'éducation
mais là avec deux missions bien
spécifiques et ce sont ces deux missions
spécifiques que nous avons voulu
retracer et expliquer pour tous dans ce
10 mai dans le décrypter de manière
chronologique pardon où vous avez des
thématiques plus tôt dont il ya des
thématiques
il ya surtout beaucoup de témoignages de
photographies c'est surtout une tranche
de vie parce que le lycée militaire de
saint cyr dont je vous disais c'est un
projet qui est très original en termes
éducatifs et ce qu'on apprend le
séminaire saint cyr s'est pas seulement
des matières pédagogique ce pas
seulement passer son bac enrichir leur
concours à une grande école c'est aussi
un savoir être et c'est ce savoir être
que l'on a voulu montrer ça se passe
comment il y a des ça ne font pas
nécessairement qu'à l'école le court on
va dire puisque vos élèves dorment sur
place
voilà la spécificité de notre lycée
c'est tout d'abord deux missions que
j'aimerais expliquer parce qu'elles sont
souvent pas connu et c'est pour ça qu'on
a écrit ce livre c'est d'abord l'aide de
la famille
c'est à dire que dans les classes du
secondaire nos enfants les parents nos
enfants sont des militaires à 70 % à 15
% des fonctionnaires et 15% des
boursiers je profite d'ailleurs de
l'antenne pour dire que nous pouvons
accueillir des boursiers des yvelines si
leur niveau scolaire le leur permet mais
ce sera avec avec grand plaisir bien sûr
nous avions fait un sujet avait avec
vous lors de la cérémonie où vous avez
plus de demande que de reçus c'est lié
aussi à ce que l'on trouve dans cet
ouvrage scellier est ce que l'on trouve
dans cet ouvrage c'est lié à nos
résultats serrés lier relier c'est lié à
cet excellent ce qu'on essaie de
promouvoir c'est lié à ce régime de vie
bien particulier qui l'internât et au
fait que nous avons d'un côté cohabitent
et vivent ensemble et travaillent
ensemble bien des équipes d'éducation
nationale le professeur et puis aussi
bien aux cadres militaires et tout ça
donne une alchimie qui je crois
fonctionne très très bien vous parlez
des témoignages ce sont des anciens
élèves des anciens professeurs qui
s'exprime dans l'orage
voilà des anciens à l'aide des anciens
professeurs qui pour certains d'entre
eux on a pris tous les témoignages des
monnaies du chef d'état major de l'armée
de terre par exemple qui a fait de sa
sixième jusqu'à sa classe
deux classes préparatoires au lycée
militaire de sens hier mais aussi des
mères de familles qui sont passées par
là et voilà on a tous les tout le panel
d'élèves possible et leurs témoignages
dans cette solide on en a beaucoup parlé
c'est la vie quotidienne quelle est elle
dans son essai qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce
qu'on trouve dans l'ouvragé
quand vous parlez de ça dans la vie
quotidienne on a montré comme les
comment la vie quotidienne comment
l'internât la vie en internat commandes
et été rythmée par différents moments
importants que sont bien le lever
ensuite bien le petit déjeuner puis ce
qu'on appelle le rassemblement c'est à
dire que par section les classes se
rassemble enfin les classes ce sont des
sections elles se rassemblent tous les
matins et puis ensuite bien le début des
cours et puis le sport qui a oui vous
êtes qu'elle nous attachons énormément
d'importance au sein du lycée tournoi
des tournois et on peut parler du
tournoi interarmées des lycées de
défense parce que il ya un concept allie
cette défense et l'armée de terre à
quatre hélices et de défense un donc
associé à l'école un autre à la flèche
un troisième à autun est en fait un
quatrième aix en provence et nous
fonctionnons pratiquement sur le même
modèle et vous parler de l'avenir parce
que l'histoire continue de s'écrire avec
notamment d'ouvrir des nouvelles
filières si on parle de l'aspect
scolaire alors sur pour l'aspect
scolaire on ouvre des nouvelles filières
nous avons maintenant des sti 2d c'est à
dire en première et en terminale
et puis leur prolongement avec un bts
systèmes numériques informatique et
réseaux option cyber défense qui est un
projet totalement original en france au
coeur de l'actualité
voilà et nos élèves ces élèves là ont
vocation à servir et bien au sein
désormais au sein de services
spécialisée dans le domaine des cyber
défense personnelle alors le livre a le
lycée militaire de saint-cyr faim quant
aux histoires et édité aux éditions un
lavauzelle pendant quelques instants
nous parlerons musée qu'elle les deux
autres invités grégoire beaumont et
bruno guérin les membres de tiger woods
mais avant un mot sur un ouvrage
c'est le fruit de 24 ans de travail
claude rodriguez photographe
professionnel a rassemblé plus de 200
photos du golf national du golf de saint
quentin en yvelines
dans un ouvrage parcours de lumière on
l'écouté il était au micro de patrice
carmouze plus je m'emploie à faire
découvrir les parcours de golf d'une
façon différente que les connaisseurs le
connaissent pas ce que les golfeurs
icaunais chez un homme sportif
le truc c'est un très beau et chaud de
serre entendre coup m'a pas du tout chez
c'est le paysage qui m'intéresse il l'a
la méditation que je trouve saint gall
chez le ch il hanche ce week-end c'était
la rentrée des grands formats au théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines il y avait
trois concerts programmés parmi eux
celui de fred pallem et du sacre du
tympan un concert un peu particulier les
musiciens n'ont joué que des musiques de
films d'animation et de dessins animés
patrick jacques de dixmude s'est glissée
dans la salle regarder sur le continent
l'aménagement des 3000 est dans nos
mains par la télévision
avouez vous aussi vous l'avez reconnu le
thème de l'inspecteur gadget créé en
1983 aux instruments les onze musiciens
du sacre du tympan avec cartoon les
artistes explorent les dessins animés et
films d'animations si je fais un
programme comme ça il faut que je fasse
un programme avec des musiques qui me
plaisent et dans lequel les musiciens
peuvent faire des choses aussi peuvent
s'amuser mais quand on l'a montait je
n'avais aucune idée du retentissement
que ces musiques et ce répertoire peut
avoir auprès d'un jeune public ce j'en
avais jamais fait au départ c'est
vraiment ciblé enfants et moi ce que
j'adore c'est quand il ya les enfants et
en a là c'est rigolo parce que du coup
pendant le concert les parents il ya des
trucs qui connaissent mieux mieux qu'eux
que les enfants et vice versa
[Musique]
créée en 1998 par fred pallem avec des
musiciens rencontrés sur les bancs du
conservatoire de paris
le sacre du tympan mêle musique
populaire et musique savante les
premiers dessins animés sont
essentiellement ce essentiellement de la
musique de jazz mais bon là on fait pas
que du jazz il ya un peu de tout il ya
du rock
il ya toutes les particularités c'est
qu'évidemment il ya des thèmes avec des
mélodies qui sont très catchy qu'on
reconnaît très vite
[Musique]
c'est toujours très très rythmé et la
musique pour les enfants c'est toujours
très expressionniste quoi il faut que
les effets soient énormes
50 ans de musique retracé en une heure
de concert un spectacle pour les petits
mais aussi pour l'écran où le plaisir de
les coudes se mêlent vie au jeu de celui
qui reconnaîtra le plus vite
[Musique]
c'est la fin on continue avec nos deux
invités grégoire beaumont et bruno
guerra de membres de highway est un
jeune groupe francilien certain nombre
sont même yvelinois on le précise alors
le groupe a été lancée en 2014 et vous
venez jouer du rock stoner pas d'erreur
c'est bien ça un peu l'histoire de ce
groupe tenu 14
comment ça vous êtes prêt à rencontrer
le groupe a commencé fin 2014
je les crée
à la batterie et au chant avec une autre
personne qui furent tous les groupes
maintenant après deux heures d'audition
j'ai recruté bretons à la guitare et au
chant maintenant puis enfin gilles la
basse et au chant
c'est un groupe qui a sorti une démo du
coup fin 2015 on a mis un an pour sortir
quelque chose qu'on a autoproduit donc
on enregistrait nous-mêmes mixer etc
s'en sont suivis des concerts à paris et
en province des petites tournées 3 4
dates et hélas du coup un enregistrement
à la batterie guyancourt sur un six
titres en dire quelques mots encore tout
à l'heure un peu plus tard parce que on
a parlé du rock stoner est ce que
quelqu'un peut expliquer ce que c'est
tout le monde ne connaît pas ce style de
musique
nous venons peut-être c'est du bruit
c'est une influence plutôt black sabbath
led zeppelin pour les anciens groupes
entre les jeux le groupe après des trucs
plus récents comme tsf tonné jeu ça peut
peut-être parler à quelqu'un et vous
faites la base c'était des jeunes qui
sont eux qui semble qu'ils s'ennuyaient
a fait beaucoup de temps libre et puis
la musique dans le désert justement on a
parlé vous serez aussi 6 octobre
prochain donc la semaine prochaine à la
batterie de guyancourt en première
partie de seven weeks avant d'en parler
un peu plus on écoute un extrait
alors tant détesté
voilà
[Musique]
alors on l'a vu à l'antenne à côté à
côté de nous le titre cède déserte
spirit peut-être un petit mot sur ce
morceau je pense que ça reflète le
stoner en général pour nous après ces
paroles qui qui qui disent beaucoup de
choses forcément maintenant dans la
continuité moi ce que je veux quand on
fait une compo enfin on est très sûr eu
un gros bruit donc forcément des paroles
qui revendique aussi bas que jose de
gros ont forcément celui des sentiments
des choses qui se sont passées pour nous
mais voilà ça reflète le rôle vous
sortez un ep de six titres qui devrait
sortir en novembre vous êtes en train de
peaufiner leur travail et qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on tombe dessus caisse
comment vous l'avez travailler ccc
longuement mûri ces les morceaux vous
été testée déjà en concert c'est que
tout le monde ses dimensions que fond
concernant manière un cd mort faut aussi
qu'ils sont issus d'anciennes compo
depuis 2014 qu'on avait gardées qu'on
avait jamais enregistrée et des
nouvelles qu'on a refait du coup avec
gil qui a intégré le groupe il ya près
d'un an maintenant
donc du coup il ya il ya des différences
entre les deux on voit maintenant chacun
met sa patte maintenant aux compositions
donc à chacun porte un riff un peu de
batterie des du chant etc
du coup forcément mais une évolution oui
on peut dire que là dessus
grand dieu vous jurer que deux morceaux
inédits en concert où vous vous jouer
des morceaux de vos inspirations eux
on joue kono composent ça c'est sûr
après y'a pas d'inédits dont joue tout
ce qu'on a tous notre répertoire quand
on le peut la semaine prochaine on va
jouer qu'une heure ont forcément pour
pas jouer tout mais quand on peut on
jouer vous tous répertoires dix chansons
tout exactement vos références on avait
sorti quelques jeunes ya aussi pas le
même palm desert 101 groupe de hard rock
américain
astro queen là c'est plutôt du black
metal si je me trompe pas ou encore led
zeppelin je pense que c'est plus connus
on n'a pas trop besoin de les présenter
mais vous faites un livre tout ça vous
vous en inspirer que comment vous
comment vous les prenez ces exemples
fois là c'est une très bonne question
après moi je suis à la batterie donc
forcément
quand j'ai commencé la batterie quand
j'ai quand j'avais 16 ans j'écoutais je
connais tous ces groupes des jeunes
groupes comme les écumes nouveaux
groupes comme gekko est encore
actuellement et je vois en concert dont
je m'inspire de tous ces groupes là pour
créer mon jeu de batterie qui est un jeu
très typé stoner c'est sans voix du
poids voilà après dans les compos enfin
même bruno qui joue très impliqué avec
beaucoup de soul aux fins s'inspire de
tous ces groupes là aussi quoi avec
aussi un gros son puis j'ai amené sur
les solos exactement voilà ça vous
permet c'est peut-être une musique qui
permet de se défouler ou est-ce que là
on range dans du cliché
au final ce n'est pas ça le rock stoner
je me défoule à un petit mot aussi sur
la batterie qu'à une place dans votre
groupe
finalement parce que ils ont enregistré
là-bas vous vous répétez là bas une
scène comme ça pour en faire une
première partie de saison mx qu'un
groupe qui date des années du début de
nuit c'est aussi pour permettre de vous
ouvrir plus tard pour vous faire
connaître
on aimerait bien ça c'est sûr maintenant
ça risque un rêve
très gros rêve du coup nous on est juste
très très fier qu'on vous et l'excellent
accès à ce concert-là pour jouer en
première partie où on remercie
christophe commencé j'ai eu la batterie
c'est des gens qui nous ont supportés
depuis le début sachant qu'on a commencé
avec eux par une espèce de stations
vertes
du coup on a été sélectionné pour jouer
et du coup depuis on a créé des métiers
avec eux on enregistrait avec en fait
beaucoup de choses avec eux je pense que
s'arrêtera pas donc du coup très très
content de voir jouer dans celui en plus
qui est tellement mythique la batterie
et
sur une grosse scène ce que c'est
vraiment une très grosse scène donc
c'est vraiment intéressant d'avoir un
super sub quoi wall avait enregistré 1 2
p de six titres vous espérez bien sûr
j'imagine plus tard faire plus vous êtes
amateur swiss le groupe
comment comment on prépare des concerts
comme ça quand on quand on est amateur
travail on fête le week-end on va
peut-être le soir qu'on peut mais enfin
après ça fait longtemps qu'on pratique
d'instruments donc geste alors tout seul
on arrive au rock stoner s'est pas
nécessairement ce qu'on écoute jeunes ça
veut dire des parents ça vient de moi
j'ai commencé avec du punk c'était des
potes de lycée et qui m'ont fait
découvrir et puis bon on voit des filles
en délit de deux ans découvre d'autres
trucs de trucs mon frère qui m'a fait
découvrir led zeppelin
donc on va par étaient de citer et puis
de fil en aiguille voilà on découvre
d'autres trucs et puis bah je suis tombé
dans le stoner à linge continue je
continue d'écouter d'autres trucs
vous n'arrêtez jamais de chercher des
références j'imagine
merci à tous les deux d'être venu en
plateau alors pour écouter les iron will
c'est le 6 octobre à la batterie et on
ouvre maintenant une page cinéma
si vous ne savez pas à quoi allez voir
au cinéma cette semaine syrie la date de
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois vous donne un conseil
écoutez cette semaine notre coup de
coeur et le film barbara réalisé par
mathieu amalric avec jeanne balibar une
actrice va jouer barbara le tournage va
commencer bientôt
elle travaille son personnage la voie
des chansons des partitions des gestes
le tricot les scènes à apprendre ça va
ça avance ça grandit jusqu'à l'envahir
le réalisateur aussi travail par ces
rencontres par les archives par la
musique il laisse submerger en verre
comme elle part elle les images de
barbara et de jeanne balibar se
confondent et nous confondent dans une
illusion parfaite et troublante
le spectateur ne sait plus très bien qui
est qui
des archives et les images de fiction
les chansons et les notices
biographiques le châtelet et google le
spectaculaire et l'intimé la satire et
l'hommage le rêve et la réalité
ce film magnifique nous dessinent par
petites touches le portrait de la grande
barbara un peu dévoilé mais toujours
aussi mystérieuse mathieu amalric fait
de jeanne balibar une troublante barbara
de cinéma cette dernière est remarquable
dans une prestation qui va bien au delà
de limitation barbara est à découvrir
cette semaine à l'espace philippe noiret
un mot sur une avant-première celle du
troisième film de fabrice éboué qu'il
présentait dimanche dernier à l'ugc
skywest coexister raconte l'histoire de
nicolas producteur de musique en
difficulté qui décident de monter un
groupe composé d'un curé d'un rabbin et
d'un imam patrick jacq de d'xp de la
rencontre est pour nous la religion pour
moi c'est juste un prétexte pour que les
trois bras cassés se rencontrent et
finalement la seule religion qui vont
avoir si tu allais faire marcher
ensemble c'est la musique
mais c'était plus parler d'un d'un
groupe fabrique et pour un succès pour
parler d'eux c'est ce que ce soit
l'humour où la musique aujourd'hui on
appartient tous à des grands groupes qui
font aussi bien effectivement de la
charcuterie que de la lingerie que de la
musique oui du comique
la semaine prochaine nous parlerons du
festival de bande dessinée de but car
rendez vous incontournable de la saison
culturelle yvelinoise le maire de la
commune nous parlera de la programmation
elle sera accompagnée de marc bourgne
dessinateur de michel vaillant depuis
2012 mais des rendez vous sont déjà
notés pour les plus impatients et rock
l'auteur des profs sera en dédicace à
l'hôtel d'agglomération de versailles
grand parc pour rencontrer mathilde
domecq l'auteur de base il y mêle bas
rendez vous à la bibliothèque de
viroflay et la médiathèque de jouy en
josas accueille rennes christophe alvès
à l'origine de justin d'orgue le théâtre
espace coluche de plaisir vous emmène en
hand avec le bollywood masala orchestra
sur scène des musiciens des chanteurs
des danseurs ou encore des acrobates
regarder
et à
je ne dis qu'il n'y fait
oui
[Musique]
mais craint d'y enseigner du coup des
croyances et coutumes
[Musique]
décors des enseignantes et des
enseignants
dix ans
autre rendez vous au théâtre national de
51 niveler le phénomène
hofesh shechter présente grand final une
humanité en chute libre
extraits
[Musique]
on prend maintenant la direction de
saint cyr à l'école michael hirsh joue
avec les mots avec la fameuse question
enfantine pourquoi regarder houllier
oyez oyez
auj quand on est petit on rêve on fait
des plans sur la comète
et quand on est grand il paraît qu'on
rêve de faire des blancs à 3 pourquoi
être comme tout le monde je veux dire il
ya déjà plein de monde comme tout le
monde
et pourquoi il ya plusieurs religions
meilleur qu'un seul dieu non il ya
plusieurs dieux ah bon et ils sont
copains le 7 une culture est maintenant
terminée le magazine est à revoir sur
notre site internet ou sur l'application
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis et
je vous dis à mercredi prochain
[Musique]